MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's officially
week two of Google
Cloud Next OnAir, which
means we're focusing on
productivity and collaboration.
I'm Mark Mirchandani, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week two is all about
productivity and collaboration,
meaning we want
to help you work.
So we've got a
lineup of sessions
that should appeal to
everyone, including end user
tips with easier collaboration
with G Suite, advice and guides
for IT admins managing
employee resources with Chrome
Enterprise, and key
insights for decision-makers
with questions around
security and availability.
Be sure to add the talks you're
interested in to your playlist,
where you can watch
them on demand.
With the challenges of
COVID-19, things are different.
At Google, our focus
is on how to adapt
both internal and
externally, which
is why we use the same
products that we offer.
That's why I'm excited
about the solution keynote
this week with Javier
Soltero, the vice
president and general
manager for G Suite.
He'll share some context
on how G Suite aims
to enable employees to have
impact wherever they are.
Javier is also joined by
Hilda Clune, the technology
and transformation leader
of PricewaterhouseCoopers,
so that you can hear directly
from a company relying on G
Suite to empower their people.
One session on my own
playlist is G Suite
for Developers, where
Charles Maxson will
give an overview
of the many ways
to build tools with G Suite.
There's a full
spectrum of options,
from low-code tools that enable
users to build customizations
to the APIs and
professional tools
that empower software
vendors to build integrations
with G Suite.
Add it to your own
playlist to check it out.
Finally, as we move further
into this virtual conference
experience and discuss
the virtual tools to get
our work done, it
seems only right
that we highlight a demo
with a virtual pro tip.
It's hard to feel
connected to your team
when your office
is closed, which
makes a remote-friendly
all-hands a useful tool
for keeping that team spirit.
This video demo
shows you how you
can use Google Meet to host
a fully online all-hands
with up to 100,000 viewers.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Do you have any
thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.